Here's the equation we want to solve. Great work if you found this one. I know
this one was tough. The key idea to get started is to assign the variable. I
think it's best to let x equal the time it takes for the slower person. If we
let x equal the number of hours it takes the slower person to carpet the room,
then we can use 1 over x for the first fraction. This would be one job
completed in x hours. The faster person works in 6 hours less time. So this
means the second person could complete that same job, one job in x minus 6
hours. Now we don't know who's faster Jamal or Danielle, we just know that the
faster person does in in x minus 6 hours and the slower person does it in x
hours. If we add the slower person's rate to the faster person's rate, we'll
get 1 4th. One job completed in 4 hours. This is the amount it takes Jamal and
Danielle to carpet the room together.